[Musique]
je suis candidate aux élections
législatives parce que c'est une
évidence c'est le moment de faire
rentrer dans la vie politique des
personnalités comme la mienne une élue
de terrain sérieuse sincère et créative
je suis connecté avec la génération
d'avant et la génération d'après jeu
réunit donc toutes les qualités pour
être la meilleure des candidates sur la
troisième circonscription des pyrénées
orientales
je prépare sa campagne depuis plusieurs
mois et je peux vous assurer que nous
avons ici toutes les personnes les
ressources et des projets pour devenir
un grand territoire l'écologie avec nos
énergies renouvelables retrouver notre
fierté agricole et notre prééminence et
enfin construire notre filière du
numérique et du digital
parce que c'est l'histoire de ma famille
d'hommes et de femmes qui ont fait le
choix courageux de défendre et servir
notre pays parce que c'est seulement au
nom des valeurs de la droite que nous
arrivons à restaurer l'autorité de
l'état en rassemblant libérant et
protégeant je suis là pour vous défendre
et je serai à vos côtés pendant les cinq
prochaines années
[Musique]